buonasera buonasera a tutti
qualche anno fa quando i miei genitori
mi guardavano mentre strimpellavo le mie
tastiere
mi dicevano sempre che mi stavo
baloccando con la musica e non la stavo
suonando seriamente effettivamente devo
dire che avevano ragione perché io la
musica l'ho sempre considerata come un
gioco come una sperimentazione come un
ascoltare qualcuno riprovare a rifarlo e
poi in base ai miei gusti personali
sulla musica provare a realizzare delle
delle piccole canzoni e poi mi
permettevano di cercare di imitare quei
cantanti o quei musicisti che mi
piacevano di più
per questo motivo io la musica non l'ho
mai studiata seriamente l'ho imparato a
leggere con molta fatica a scrivere
ancora più fatica e per questo motivo ho
sempre avuto un piccolo complesso di
inferiorità dentro di me devo essere
onesto perché vedevo tanti musicisti
molti miei amici che erano bravissimi a
suonare mentre io a suonare non sono mai
stato un granché e ho sempre fatto
suonato musica orecchio fondamentalmente
anche andando in giro con tante band e
nella mia vita eccetera però non avevo
mai questa soddisfazione di saper
suonare bene allora io da un certo punto
di vista in poi ho deciso di portare il
mio concetto di musica a un altro punto
di vista basato più sulla fisica del
suono sullo studio della fisica del
suono sullo studio delle forme d'onda
che creano i suoni e poi sulla
realizzazione dei circuiti elettronici
che mi avrebbero permesso fuori di
creare le mie canzoni soprattutto
diciamo nell'ambito della musica
elettronica e di una ricerca nella
realizzazione di suoni particolarmente
fittizi cioè elettronici molto spinti
ecco io ho sempre basato il mio studio
su diciamo 4 mattoncini fondamentali che
sono diciamo un po le forme d'onda su
cui ogni musicista di musica
elettronica si deve prima o poi
confrontare la prima di il primo
mattoncino di questi è l'onda
sinusoidale londra sinusoidale quella
più simile a i suoni della natura è
quella più naturale ed è una cosa
talmente naturale che non è bella fa
così come sentite è un suono che non
dice tanto soprattutto nella
composizione musicale un suono del
genere non ha molto senso
allora diciamo chi progetta circuiti
elettronici per la realizzazione di di
musica elettronica appunto può per
esempio pensare di raddrizzare i lati
verticali e di tagliare l'estremità apre
ottenere una cosa del genere un'onda
quadra che è esattamente l'opposto
rispetto all onda sinusoidale è
completamente fittizia completamente
fredda come si dice in gergo è molto
acido
e non è neanche tanto bella da ascoltare
forse se non ci si fa qualche altro
maltrattamento sopra per esempio ne
possiamo tagliare il lato sinistro e
ottenere una cosa un po più morbida un
suono un po più nasale che si chiama
honda dente di sega ed è quello che ho
utilizzato diciamo dal sottoscritto
sicuramente per fare i miei test delle
mie canzoni e la mia musica ed è un
suono diciamo che a metà tra la musica
diciamo classica quella del suono
diciamo della onda sinusoidale e quello
dell'onda dell'onda quadra e l'onda
dente di seguire un po più comunque
immaginate che ognuno di questi suoni
permette di in qualche modo di essere
rimescolato insieme di essere attaccato
di essere stiracchiato per ottenere
tutte le note della tastiera anzi molte
di più perché come dice rocco tanica di
elio e le storie tese tra un tasto
bianca un tasto nero c'è un sacco di
roba lì dentro
ed è lì che noi che facciamo musica
elettronica andiamo a basare il nostro
studio
ecco diciamo tutti questi mattoncini si
basano tutti su un pezzettino di silicio
piccolino così piccolissimo che non si
vede effettivamente si vede solo se ve
lo faccio vedere quassù ed è un
transistor un transistor è un oggetto
che io tanti anni fa ho incontrato al
corso di elettronica quando studiavo
all'università ma non ci siamo rimasti
molto simpatici a vicenda in realtà non
avevo capito come funzionava
l'ho rincontrato molti anni dopo quando
mi sono interessato di elettronica open
source soprattutto basata su schede come
arduino o roba del genere utilizzata
principalmente per la realizzazione di
circuiti per la domotica e per le
telecomunicazioni allora sono entrato in
contatto diciamo con una
ha un retroterra un numero di persone
meravigliose che si occupano da sempre
sia di musica sia di elettronica e hanno
provato a mischiare insieme le loro due
passioni per ottenere degli strumenti
realizzati in casa diciamo che si
possono basare oltre sui tre mattoncini
e vi ho fatto vedere prima anche su
qualcosa di leggermente più duro che
qualcuno potrebbe considerare diciamo
non troppo interessante all'ascolto ma
che se ben modulato può dare delle
soddisfazioni soprattutto nella
progettazione di batterie elettroniche
ed è il rumore il rumore in questo caso
il rumore bianco ora ve lo faccio
ascoltare l'avete già sentita in realtà
è quello che si ascolta quando una radio
non è sulla frequenza
ecco nella musica elettronica anche una
sorgente sonora di questo tipo può avere
il suo senso cioè può essere utilizzata
con successo
ecco tornando al milan nel mio cammino
all'interno della community dei
musicisti esperti di elettronica e delle
sperimentazioni per la realizzazione di
strumenti elettronici sono passato dalla
modifica dei giocattoli
questo per esempio in particolare è una
tassa e una tastiera e cravatta che ho
acquistato per pochi euro in un
negozietto lo modificata ci ho attaccato
una scheda un arduino miniaturizzato e
l'ho trasformato in un controllore di
strumenti musicali di sintetizzatori
fondamentalmente ecco da lì in poi il
mio percorso è andato mettendo tutti
questi i mattoncini sempre più complessi
uno sopra l'altro per cercare di
costruire delle diciamo delle
architetture leggermente più difficili
ecco per esempio una cosa del genere un
noise machine basato su arduino che
diciamo al suo interno appunto a un
algoritmo e viene implementato
all'interno della scheda open source più
famosa in questo momento è intorno c'è
tutta una circuiteria e mi permette in
tempo reale durante l'esecuzione di
cambiare i parametri del suono e genera
rumore sequenziale dall'esterno
l'oggetto appare in questa maniera
quindi di conseguenza
tu puoi avere a disposizione vari
parametri da modificare il pitch la
forma d'onda la frequenza dei tagli la
velocità della sequenza è il tipo di
ripetizione della sequenza oltre che
ovviamente il volume
ecco da qui in poi mi sono basato invece
sulla costruzione di sintetizzatori
analogici e quindi sono andato un altro
pezzettino più avanti in un attimino
oltre passando per esempio attraverso la
realizzazione di macchine come questa
questo è un progetto open source di una
di un gruppo di persone americano che si
chiama rockit e io l'ho preso l'ho
modificato secondo i miei diciamo i miei
obiettivi e ho realizzato questo
sintetizzatore a doppio oscillatore con
un filtro passa basso un figlio
passabanda è un filtro passa alto più un
generatore di sviluppo e tante altre
feature che tra poco ascolterete e
all'esterno l'ho realizzato così lo
vedete qui davanti ma la cosa più
importante di tutto questo sono i
fianchetti in legno perché i fianchetti
in legno sono fondamentali per qualunque
musicista cui piaccia diciamo il vintage
ecco ed è nel nostro mondo della musica
elettronica è una cosa piuttosto
importante ecco da qui in poi sono
andato ancora avanti e ho realizzato
altri tipi di sintetizzatore questo per
esempio un mii blip che anche questo è
un progetto che io italianizzato lo reso
più veloce ho cambiato il software o
modificato l'interfaccia esterne dopo ne
ho realizzato anche per questo una
scatola esterna disegnata da me che è
questa è come notate non ci sono più i
fianchetti legno perché tutta di legno e
ancora più vintage e quindi c'è più
soddisfazione a suonarla ecco diciamo a
questo punto lasciamo la parola alla
musica perché nel ringraziarvi per
avermi dato l'opportunità di essere qui
per raccontarvi un po delle mie
esperienze nel mondo della musica
elettronica
nel ringraziare l'organizzazione che mi
ha invitato vi voglio dire un'ultima
cosa che creare oggetti che serviranno
per creare i suoni con cui poi creerete
la vostra musica in realtà è una
soddisfazione che non si può spiegare la
potete solo provare nel mio caso è
quello di suonare davanti a voi oggi a
suonare fuori i miei strumenti davanti a
un pubblico non si riesce diciamo a
descrivere questa soddisfazione perché è
creare per creare per creare quindi a
creare alla terza o all'ennesima potenza
se volete perché tutte le volte che io
mette le mani sul mio strumento e mi
rendo conto diciamo di quello che ho
fatto anche mettendo in piedi un piccolo
processo produttivo la produzione delle
schede il montaggio dei componenti il
teste eccetera
mi rendo conto io l'ho sempre preso come
un gioco e lo prenderò per sempre come
un gioco
però sento il risultato vedo il
risultato mi rendo conto se sono andato
leggermente al di là sia della musica
che del gioco e ora vi faccio sentire
una piccola improvvisazione di musica
sequenziale in onore dei tangerine dream
degli anni 70
no
grazie